hey everybody so bear with me for just a
minute I'm getting the last of my stuff
sort of fired up and going so I don't
have the chat yet just give me a minute
I'm working on it
but I hope everyone is having a lovely
evening and has had a nice translator in
this week here we go yes I did that
here we go my evening is thesis writing
Oh what's your thesis on good evening
yes okay
there we go so I don't um necessarily
have much in the way of planned things
to talk about but I didn't I feel really
bad I lose track of when stuff is so
like once it was brought to my attention
that this was trans Awareness Week I was
like oh crap you know I would love to do
something a recognition of it but I
don't have the time to get a video but
you know I can presents decide myself
here like I did for Pride earlier in the
year so there we go the thing you or is
it Veera tonight sweetie it's still
whatever you're feeling my I shift in my
presentation does not correspond to a
definitive shift in preferences I always
say whatever makes the most sense for
you to say whatever makes sense in your
head that's you can say and if if it
turns out to not work for me I will
bring it to your attention
don't worry about it Carolyn I think we
might have someone you might need to
clip the wings on I keep an eye on that
ah love because oh I I love these frames
I adore these frames they're so nice oh
hi there Callie looking fabulous either
way I will take it
a roald dahl made some excellent works
of fiction but good god he had he had a
very comically McCobb sense of humor
some of his works is seen as traumatic
in some ways not sure how we got onto
Roald Dahl but yes yeah he like I
haven't verified this ID
stories that he actually didn't like
kids very much
um but yeah he's he has a very dark
Sensibility and a very dark sense of
humor at times which I think it is also
kind of very British hang on let me get
on I'm drinking and no it's not water
this time because I am a grown-ass
person and I can drink what I dang well
please let's see what color is the
lipstick I really need to learn color
and brand names and remember them for
what I'm wearing because whenever I get
asked that and it's the same with the
nails I never know if top my head and
then I feel like a jackass for not being
able to answer that so I don't know uh
see that's right anything you can have
t-tonight more than water
a grown-ass person or grown-ass person
depends on who you ask us pose my nails
are the same coming out lovely it's
funny because I'd done the nails before
so they don't really match the sort of
darker palette I went with the makeup
cuz I hadn't planned to have the match
so this is almost distractingly bright
compared to the rest of what I've got
going on since you asked oh this is um
is what you're working on simulation of
n mr spectra from md trajectories
application to solid state 2h NMR to
deuterated MT be a guest host guest
crystals does that mean anything to
anyone
oh yeah no I totally understood that I
just figured you would want to explain
it
given time lords can switch genders do
you think most of them go by
gender-fluid I believe they perceived
gender completely different to us and
have different words for it um like this
question has come up a few times in
terms of the the time lords and whether
they would be considered gender fluid by
the strictest definition yes by in terms
of like would I consider them to be
gender fluid representation it gets a
little bit more if he for me because
that there is a very there's a very hard
cutoff in terms of when they are one or
the other and my general suspicion is
the time was probably don't have a
perception of gender in the same way
that we do and I would also imagine they
probably don't put as much weight behind
the concept of gender as we do um it's
hard to say though you might have seen
in the discord I started watching Shira
right after you talked about it I'm only
a few episodes in but I'm loving you so
far oh very happy to see that car I did
know and I did notice that um when when
you brought it up in the discord yes it
was it was great to see I'm always happy
to spread the gospel of Shira I'm going
to Minnesota on Friday to see my
relatives maybe I might end up running
into Lewis Love hog that would be
humorous that would be very cool he's on
my list of youtubers I would love to
meet but of course like no one's local
to me I say that um the Doctor Who guide
is actually semi local he's a commutable
distance from me but as within anything
trying to figure out schedules is a
nightmare when gender-fluid people
freeze do they become gender solid yes
and when we get overheated we become
gender gasps don't think about that too
much whether or not computer simulations
of molecular dynamics
can be used to predict the results of of
a specific test stop me anytime um that
sounds incredibly academic and power to
you I weigh over my head
Eddie Izzard has a joke about being
gender flew about being gender liquid
I'm sure he does I I got a I gotta see
what he's been up to lately I know he
was talking about running for politics
which I really hope he goes through with
and I hope he gets into coz I'm at
imagine him debating in Parliament oh
that would be amazing
just here to say hi have a nice day
everyone well how do you - I heard trans
I came yes the trans signal pulsing
softly in the night calling all forth I
recently wrote a paper on how drinking
is good for you I might have been drunk
while I like a rubbed it um well like at
so many things then you know in
moderation so Cheers
oh and someone had asked what I have
here is I have apple cider and mulled
Mead and also the cider if you've ever
gotten just straight-up apple cider it
can on occasion just ferment on its own
which this did so I do effectively have
hard cider with meat at it as a time
like myself I can confirm me have no
care about gender like on this strange
planet god I miss Gallifrey hello there
Elizabeth thank you very much
I'm pinging on dreamer fur from
Supergirl you look great I've only just
encountered dreamer um I I skipped the
second half of season 3 I really wasn't
digging it but on Liz's encouragement I
have started on season 4 I am not very
far into it so I but I did get to her
coming out which was very nice to see
I'm liking her so far certainly as
represent
I don't have as much of a sense of her
as a character as I'm going to need to
fully form an opinion but it's off to a
good start so far are you a fan of Ozzy
Osbourne's music not exceptionally I
don't dislike it but it's it's not
really my jam I think it's just what it
boils down to Omid young yet meat is
wonderful
we Liz has a friend who owns a meatery
which is where i got this mead from she
so she's like she makes this local
meatery she she makes meat in her garage
and it's great oh I I have great friends
and so does Liz and it's all very
wonderful thank you very much Amanda
thanks for that
god it's after midnight and I should be
studying yeah no that me seriously you
should be studying don't let me keep you
I will not be responsible for anything
for anyone
fairly out of college except for myself
I love you Doctor Who and Harry Potter
videos thank you for being so visible
and giving gender-fluid youth something
to look up to online thank you for that
it's oh it's funny it's always I never
stopped being kind of like thrown off in
a good way when I get referred to as
like representation or or in any way
inspirational or just something to to
look to or am i oh wait mm-hmm it's it's
so weird to me
does your wife sometimes do your makeup
um okay well backtrack I'm not married
I'm divorced when I was married she
helped me learn makeup um she rarely did
it after I got a handle on it my current
partner Liz I am actually more likely to
assist her with makeup than she is me so
that there's a long-winded answer to
what was a simple question one of my
former co-workers announced she was
transitioning to him
and I do wish her a happy future oh well
I I wish I I wish him the best of luck
Connor studying and watching this hello
well hello do you do a lot of people
studying is it is it like that time of
year our exams coming up is that what's
going on you have a favorite trans
character in media in general or a
favorite depiction of the trans
experience I'm not actually sure that I
do because um like most things that have
just straight up trans characters as
opposed to like cuz I watch a lot of
fantasy and sci-fi so you get weird
things were like oh it's an alien race
with no gender or things like that but
like straight-up trans characters I
don't have a ton of experience with
because they're mostly in realistic
dramas which is not my entertainment of
choice I'll try and think on that I
don't really think I have a go-to answer
though evening the thing happening
international men's day cheers to that
um hold on I had something I lost I
can't blame you for my studies failing
no sorry you can I was looking forward
to explaining that to my parents then
asking them if they were okay donating
to your patreon a minute later I'm sure
that'll go over very well are there any
things to look back on that should have
been super obvious signs about your
gender identity um super obvious no but
[Music]
there are there there are some things
that like oh right
so like things like the fact that if I
had the option in video games that I
played I pretty much always default into
the female character choice so like in
Street Fighter my favorite character to
play was chun-li and then later Cammy
when she got introduced when I play
original Diablo for my first completed
playthrough was with the rogue I I had
it if it was available as an option our
early yeah I started to have a handle on
my gender by this point but early Fire
Emblem games there are some of those
where you can pick your starting gender
and I would usually go female not with
any particularly deep thought but have
you seen Zombieland saga I'm not sure
what that is I mean I know there was
this Zombieland sequel that came out I
didn't see that double tab so I'm not
sure that's what you're referring to or
something else
the BBC fought I'm sorry
Dane your your spelling is throwing me
off here
I want to eat meat weld a gem whether
you would drink me if you have to chew
it it might not be the best meat that
you've got your hands on watched claws
last Friday it's already a Christmas
classic I will not be watching anything
Christmas related until after
Thanksgiving because I refuse to yield
background Thanksgiving is its own
holiday it is not Christmas part one
who's your go-to smash character well as
I say this realize that I have not
played a smash more current than brawl
and even that I played very little my
experience to smash is primarily
original and melee so my usual default
if I wanted to be a jerk was Kirby cuz I
would spam the rock like nobody's
business
um I actually I played original smash a
lot to the point that I would start
challenging myself and like I would have
friends over and I would play Jigglypuff
just to see if I could win play
Jigglypuff and some end I usually did I
think I can't blow your way away too
much melee I think I might've I might
have started
- Sammis a bit more at that point but
those are good games I I did try playing
the new one
I went over somebody's house they had it
on switch it is it just me or have the
characters gotten smaller on the screen
he's just smaller and smaller smaller
smaller I like yeah I felt good because
I actually won the match that I I popped
in on I'm like oh still got it but like
I walked away after that cuz I don't
know just it was very I mean it's always
been flashbang and sort of a wide camera
at times but it felt like all that stuff
was just more and I didn't I didn't love
it would you believe there was a
live-action remake of the year without a
Santa Clause because there is and it's
atrocious I'm not a huge fan of the
original year without a Santa Clause so
I mean I I suppose I mean even before
you told me it was it was real I would
have believed it because yeah
sure why not the gender binary is
quaking have you seen new Rocko's Modern
Life movie it has one character become
transient yes um I talked about this a
little while back I did see that some
people asked if I would do a video on it
ultimately decided not to because
Rocko's Modern Life was never a show
that I watched very much and so I just
it was as far as representation goes of
a trans character I thought that was
very well done and it felt very well
integrated into the kind of thing that
Rocko's Modern Life is and was but since
I was never a huge fan of Rocko's Modern
Life I figured nobody really needed to
hear from me cuz I didn't have a ton of
opinions to share you know in terms of
how or if that impacted the way the show
functioned because I didn't like it well
enough to make a call on that do you eat
hormones well depending on what your
prescription is you may ingest them
usually
it's a pill that you would take with a
beverage so no not eat necessarily my
friend has come up with a holiday called
hanksgiving where everyone has a
Thanksgiving dinner dressed as
characters played by Tom Hanks oh who
would be my go to in that scenario um
that is a tough call like honestly I
probably just slap on a suit and tie and
say that it was streamed back from
dragnet cuz I have a real soft spot for
that movie it's not good but I do like
it a lot I feel like a lot of trans
represented as most is mostly punchlines
I think that's happening less but
historically yes historically that has
been the case I'm trying to think of
examples of trans representation and
things I watch I think the only one is
Liz from American Horror Story hotel I
have forgotten most of the details of
Hotel I didn't care for it
how many Harry Potter walkins do you
have just the one I have one my daughter
has one but no only the one what would
you say is the best version of Tetris oh
my god I haven't played like I think
I've actually only played like four
versions of Tetris original NES original
Gameboy Tetris two on the Gameboy and
like I got a mobile phone version in
like 2007 like before it was even
smartphones like and you know clicking
on arrows and stuff so like I don't have
a big perspective on the house I can't
spell today don't worry about it caraway
love you all the same
I think the only trans character I can
recall is Laverne Cox and orange is the
new black by the way I met her she was
lovely she does seem lovely there are
actually a lot of I will always
appreciate oranges the new black for
being
a launching pad for a lot of really
wonderful and fascinating performers and
and character types unfortunately I just
don't like the show very much second
season was pretty good but the rest of
it he or the rest of it that I've seen
see I watched season one didn't love it
watch season two liked it pretty well
and it ended fantastically and given
what I've heard about since then I just
choose to believe there's only two
seasons of that show and it ended going
out on top first warning go to your room
second warning Guardian Livius League of
Gentlemen is awful for representation
I'm really curious about it and if it's
compulsively watch them and it's
compulsively watchable but the theater
failure to represent people with any
sense of nuances that was so sure I
never got into I remember seeing
trailers forward and just sort of being
turned off not even necessary because of
that just the humor I'd die just I
didn't laugh because I wanted to say
that your videos are really educational
and help me understand trans
representation thank you oh thank you
that's ah honestly Laverne Cox is a
goddess Oh
fair fair is YouTube better than TV
depends on what you like to watch that's
a personal taste question I wrote a
story with a transport agonist where
time travel was part of it I always
thought future you isn't the gender
you'd expect them to be an interesting
idea oh that is an interesting wrinkle
like especially if you're if you're
still figuring yourself out and you meet
a future version of yourself who has
sorted all your gender stuff out it just
gotta be like wait what you know either
confusion or or possibly just like wait
there's their stability in my future oh
I think and I think either one would be
valid zombie glance saga is anime I
think you'd like it I haven't heard of
that one I don't watch a ton of anime
not because of any dislike of it it's
just most anime series tend to be a
really big time commitment
and some I don't have so I tend to stick
to films within my and even that I am
not nearly as well-versed as as most
people who call themselves and my fans
are on YouTube so you do wins oh thank
you
the new cats trailer dropped is still
terrifying oh I might do a reaction to
that for the breakroom it's in the dock
I actually sent just us yes I did get
that I did get that from you and I am
really sorry I'm trying to get the time
to read through it um so I and I can't
make promises for web but I meant to
tell you that yes I did receive that Oh
God
speaking of things that I received I had
some stuff I had some interesting things
sent to uh sent to my PO Box first of
all um the nicest thing and I can thank
Vanessa sent me my own car blam man
which very fun I quite enjoy that there
were a couple of other things that were
sent
yeah but mm-hmm hang on one second I
will be right back oh here we go
so where can I put this that I will not
spill it there we go safe back there so
there were a couple things sent to my PO
Box one of which may have been
well-meaning but I will never know so
somebody with no return address and this
I feel like I have been sent something
like this before
but somebody just sent me a burned CD
with no note and no information on it
and I'm sorry whoever sent this to you
if you mean well by it I am not sticking
that in my computer because I don't know
what it is or who you are or where that
came from so that's getting junked
and the other thing nice makeup by the
way thank you James and the other thing
that I got again it's always a big big
flag when there's no return address and
it's blank right there
although I know this person's from North
Carolina Thank You Postal Service God's
simple plan of salvation God loves you
please read yep don't think so Oh see
that's funny to me especially because
this past Sunday I spoke at the local
Unitarian Church in my town and it was a
wonderful experience and I felt
incredibly welcomed and incredibly heard
and that was wonderful
and it's very funny to me that that
shows up after I did that that's a big
note right there hang on I'm backing up
a tiny bit don't pop the bubble wrap uh
yes with the with the curb Lane ma'am
people assume that gender is a buying
area between male and female but
actually is more of a wibbly-wobbly baha
of genndy bendy stuff ah love it ah
Rebecca stole my joke or maybe I stole
it from you went back in time to
Arabia's live stream and made it but
then oh boy so many possibilities read
it it'd be hilarious actually because
it's not as funny as you think cuz it's
mostly just a bunch of bible quotes cuz
I've been sent stuff like that before
and last one I got that one was funny
cuz it was like this this little cartoon
thing it was ridiculous
um that one's not very funny because
this jet is just like a bunch of bible
quotes and telling me that I need to be
born again and it's not anything that I
can't even like get a laugh out of I'm
not gonna mean to laugh at anyone's
beliefs but like come on who just mails
that stuff I don't get it
thanks for letting me know and feel free
to take your time
alright well justjust know I am trying
to get to it you're not the only person
who sent me stuff to read you look
absolutely fabulous tonight Thank You
Tiffany
do you know what [ __ ] tracks are because
it sounds like one of those I if I do
then I don't know them by that name is
that hard cider uh effectively yes
Jehovah's Witnesses always really freak
me out like please don't come to my
house strangers uh-huh I had I think was
last year I had some Jehovah's Witnesses
come to my door and like I don't try and
freak out anybody but it was really
funny because I go to the door and you
know I didn't have makeup on but I had I
had earrings and I have my hair like
this and I had a pink bathrobe on not
only a pink bathrobe but that this was
during the winter so I was cold that was
over on top of normal clothes
because it was big and pink and fluffy
and kept me warm but it was funny cuz it
was it was this guy and his daughter and
she she seemed fairly pleasant she you
know was a excuse us and you know he
hands me this little pamphlet and then
he basically shuttles her way spins on
his heels 180 degrees and boom they are
gone they they did not have a lot of
interest in talking to me could be worse
it could be oh wow why is it always I'm
in the middle of me reading something
that he
zooms past me could be worse could be
those religious dollar bills that people
leave for waiters oh god it's not a
thing oh that's terrible
people need tips ah there's a group at
my university they believe and they
believe in no sex before marriage which
is perfectly fine but then my boyfriend
went with her pride badges and got dirty
looks nope yeah that's always been my
thing I don't I try very hard not to
begrudge anybody their own personal
beliefs however I will be gradual your
actions and if your actions include
actively ostracizing me or people like
me I don't care what beliefs are driving
that I I'm not gonna be cool with that
and that's one of the things that really
bothers me about that general
justification for a lot of homophobic
and transphobic belief and behaviors
like well that's just what I believe
like that's fine
but you're trying to force my life to
conform to your beliefs because most
people who say that are voting for
campaigning for pushing for the
demonization of people like me and my
issue is not whether or not you
sincerely believe it religiously my
issue is the things that you are doing I
don't really care why you're doing them
whether it's a sincerely held religious
belief or because you're just a jerk I
don't care so like it serves a little
bit of useful information in terms of
what kind of person trying to put their
boot on my neck I'm dealing with but at
the end of the day I don't really care
why you are making an argument that I'm
invalid and should
exist and should be ostracized and have
my rights taken away or have rights
deprived to me that other people have I
don't really care why the fact that you
are pushing for that and pushing to
impact my life in that way that's what
matters to me cuz I have known people
who I know take issue with this I mean I
know that but they're still polite to me
they still treat me like a human being
as uncomfortable as I know I make them
and then there are others who ignore me
so aggressively that becomes a statement
of itself so there you go fifty-four
thousand Australians were surveyed
recently 45% somewhat or strongly agree
that there are more than two genders
however 38% disagree 15% are neutral
well I mean it'll be a while before we
get a hundred percent in any direction
so you know little progress um hello
there Melanie and what else have we got
here I'm the sort of person who actively
asks witnesses questions until they
become convinced I have no interest in
what they're saying Oh see you like I
wouldn't do that to a Jehovah's Witness
just because I don't it's a waste of my
time and there's like the worst I'll get
is slightly rudely blunt like I think I
did say to a Jehovah's Witness sometimes
it was I forget what they yeah or it
might even been a Mormon I don't even
know we actually have both around here
um it was something to the effect of you
know how is your how are you with God or
whatever and I think I base is that my
relationship with God's just fine thank
you for your time and that was it but
like that's about as bad as I'll get I'm
not and I have no interest in wasting
anybody's time my own included opinions
on DC bombshells I did a podcast on it
look up the tough like a girl podcast on
the fire and water network Liz and I
talked about that book so there you go
that's where you will find that
I'm tempted to go to that group and
deliver a presentation documenting why I
think Jesus was gay I think it'll go
down fine I hope you have running shoes
on if you're gonna try that one and I
wouldn't actually recommend it if only
because like and then this isn't
necessarily me judging you Ben I get the
instinct but that does still kind of
violate the fundamental don't be a jerk
rule and you just be doing it to wind
them up and that's kind of a jerk thing
to do
so you know just just think carefully
before you go out of your way to invade
their space if that makes sense I once
had a Mormon come to my door and I said
I wasn't interested because I'm Jewish
but he replied back that's okay we read
for the same first half of the Bible I
mean I suppose is technically true than
that I wouldn't turn my nose about some
new tarot but those definitely need to
be cleansed oh I guess something else
was going on there I don't have a ton of
experience with tarot cards I think
you've had a tarot reading twice maybe
things the Bible says about being trans
at zero yes yeah actually true do you
guys believe that chick-fil-a won't give
more money to anti LGBTQ groups they
promise they won't but they made that
promise before I mean thankfully for me
as far as patronage goes it's a moot
point because there's no chick-fil-a's
around where I live so it's not like I'm
giving anything up but here's the thing
about a company like that and something
similar happened with with Target a few
years ago that people seem to have
forgotten
get back an anti LGBTQ candidate I
forget what state it was in I forget
what year so but basically you know they
have since not really done that and it
is their hope that people just forget
and some people do for myself I don't
forget because to my mind just because
they stopped financially backing that
doesn't mean that they aren't still
supporting that and that may or may not
and this is a case-by-case way here's
another thing you will never hear me
being a champion of boycotts I will talk
about where I am comfortable spending my
money or not spending my money and I
will give my reasons but I expect
everyone else to make their own call I'm
not gonna tell anyone that they should
or shouldn't shop somewhere I will tell
them why I do or don't shop certain
places or lend my financial aid I
through through purchases to certain
writers artists directors etc that's not
to say no one else should it's just
saying for my conscience it's enough
people that want to sell or push
something always regret coming to my
house I'm a stay-at-home mom of six if
you knocked my door I will take your ear
off without your getting a word in or
sorry talk your ear off well Tiffany
you'd be well within your rights let's
see oh god I found some chick tracks
online and those are some of the most
toxic propaganda and the guise of
religious messages there's a notorious
track that attacks D&D is satanic
is that still going around seriously
that's some vintage BS right there that
is
eighties nonsense oh my god though I
shouldn't be that surprised when I was a
kid in the 90s and I played magic the
gather
that was satanic although I suppose to
be fair there were actually cards with
words like demonic and devil on them it
was still ridiculous but like I do fine
but yet come on now like how how stupid
do they think kids are I'm going to
worship Satan because a game told me to
I'm sorry how stupid do you believe you
your kid to be that's my big question I
promise I won't actually do that it's a
funny thought but I thought it shall
remain now I'm glad to hear that then
thank you
that's why Frollo is the scariest Disney
villain because his villainy is too real
I still haven't seen Hunchback of Notre
Dom I know I should see trying to catch
up I know Walmart is a piece of crap but
where else am I gonna get pizza at 2:00
a.m. um well if you plan your shopping
ahead of time and have frozen pizzas in
your house already your own dang home
just sayin
the tracks are old so it could be
contemporary nonsense oh man Chick
tracts are mostly from the 80s but he's
still around of course these people
never go away even Pokemon with satanic
in the 90s yep I remember that too
didn't impact me the way Magic the
Gathering did cuz I didn't play Pokemon
but yeah I remember that what about the
children yeah what about the chosen the
children are fine
like it is especially frustrating for me
in regards to you know things like
gender presentation you know people are
like you're you're confusing children
look this is only confusing to children
if you have raised them in a rigid
closed mind environment
that does not allow for the possibility
of someone like me to exist for a kid
like that
yes I am confusing that's not me saying
that you have to like indoctrinate your
kids into gender politics or
representation or anything like that
simply put kids by their default don't
get confused by me unless their
upbringing rigidly says I don't exist
that's not on me for existing that's on
you for how you're raising your kids and
not preparing them for the fact that I
do exist and they will eventually
encounter non traditional gender role
people and they will not have the tools
to cope with that if you raise them with
a closed mind so that it's confusing to
children thing I think I I I won't say
that there is no confusion that is had
by children but I would say that's more
an indictment of how of the environment
in which a child was raised than the
things in which they are countering now
that are confusing to them little
soapbox see tonight hope folks don't
mind too much I've discovered since
watching your videos I am more
understanding of LGBTQ IQ than I used to
be I quoted that survey because it
interests me how my fellow Aussies think
Oh Thank You Sammy I it's it is
wonderful to me like just just the idea
that I anything that I might have done
or put out there sort of gets people
just thinking in a different way I mean
I can't control what conclusions people
come to and I wouldn't want the power to
do that but you know if you're willing
to you know Italy at least put some
things through some some of your own
scrutiny and think about them maybe if
you hadn't before that's that's a nice
thing how have you not seen a hunchback
I kind of moved off of Disney at the
time it came out and I have not circled
back to it yet
sorry or they were also saying Harry
Potter and His Dark Materials were
astonished lee protested by the
super-religious here in the midwest well
see I haven't read his dark materials
but that one to my memory like is an
incredibly atheistic piece of fiction
like that's its driving philosophy so I
can kind of get why religious people
would feel threatened by that one at
least to the degree that I understand
his Dark Materials because again I
haven't read it the tracks are still
around but chick is dead oh okay
ever heard of different for girls it's a
very underrated movie featuring a
transgender character I don't know that
one Rebecca so no I haven't heard of
that I'm excited to watch your Harry
Potter review later I loved watching
your revisit videos those have been fun
I'm gonna be really curious to see what
it's like going back and seeing the
first fantastic beast again because I
think I might be kinder to it that I was
the first time not looking forward to
seeing the second one again now one's
get rough - because my review of that
one isn't even that old I'm not sure my
opinion will have changed much
transgender is about comfy is about as
confusing to kids as the rest of the
world is to a kid fair that's what they
mean by you'll confuse the children
they're saying you'll let kids know
that's possible yeah that's the thing
people don't want their children their
children to go down certain paths and
they think that if they can prevent them
from discovering that certain paths
exist that their kids will never be that
of course by and large people who are
trans or gay or queer or what-have-you
are non-binary or
or however it goes they are that whether
they know the words for it or not even
if you were to control someone's life so
much like their entire life
didn't let them go out into the world
didn't let them ever experience LGBTQ
representation or meet those people or
see them on television or what have you
if that child is trans or gay or queer
they are still going to be that they're
just not going to know what it is for
what it means or how to articulate it
but you won't have done anything about
it
are backing up a little bit here bear
with me
oh thanks for uh for that bit of troll
hunting heroin much much appreciated
let's see God the authority and that one
is portrayed as the first angel
naturally-occurring creatures attended
to assert himself as the one over all
those that His Dark Materials you're
talking about again I'd like I just
don't know could you sing I'm alive from
next to normal on your break room
channel I Gabri Gabriel's part is a
little high for me
it's a little out of my range I can't
sing Dan quite well though so like in my
dream I would love to be in next to
normal but I would want to play Dan I
mean first of all I'm too old to play
game anyways but Dan's in my range like
properly so I could actually sing that
part I don't know I'm I'm very
self-conscious about my singing because
I used to be better at it than I am I
haven't kept up you know practice or and
I've lost a lot of the little sort of
tricks that I used to I used to be
better about so I don't know I still
enjoy singing but I am I'm very
self-conscious about it at this point
as in most continuities the God in His
Dark Materials is the patriarchal
ass-munch yeah it's it like I I am gonna
have to confront His Dark Materials to
some degree but I really do worry
because I really feel like more often
than not when
Sterne people be they writers or
comedians or what-have-you make broad
sweeping statements about how awful God
is it's always the Christian God that
they're templating off of and that's
frustrating because in a way that kind
of validates that one perception of what
God can be in the first place because
that's the oume that ever gets debunked
by this kind of work and that's annoying
to me I would much rather see it expand
out to incorporate the much wider
variety of what the divine might be
beyond just the big dude with beard I
mean that said if we got a rip on
Christianity or you know the Bible Old
Testament spec Old Testament God is a
jerk he's a raging alcoholic is his
temperament in that first book so I
suppose New Testament is is what got
written after he went into a a I'm going
to hell already was going there
according to some people so no worries
I heard doctor who was airing January
1st seems like an unfounded rumor to me
yeah I haven't heard anything that I can
even come close to verifying like
somebody today linked to something on
the council Games Facebook that was
dealing in the rumor mill and I just I I
didn't take it down I did kind of ask
politely that that they not opposed that
because like I just don't wanna um which
they did and they did take it down that
was nice check my Twitter they just
released the biggest study of trans kid
that debunks that completely oh well
trans gamer girl I will have to check
that out once I am off here does patreon
give you stats oh hang on
ah stupid thing does patreon give you oh
I hate this thing sometimes it really is
a pain in my butt does patreon give you
stats on what your patrons also support
it'd be interesting to see what you
overlap with well no
not really I mean I can always pull if I
wanted to I could pull my patreon
supporters you know how did you find me
what sort of stuff do it but like I I
don't want to over do like sort of data
mining my support like I I feel like I
get enough information off google
analytics I go for YouTube so that that
gets me by and yes I do have to check
out the discord I am accepting that this
this stream is gonna run long this time
so troll on the dungeon oh do we have
another one yeah we did excuse me I'm
laid to do homework what is trans
Awareness Week it's exactly what it
sounds like it is a week to be more
aware of trans people and the trans
experience Cheers
I actually saw next to normal a few
months ago without knowing what the
twist was oh you lucky devil that's a
great show I really want to be in that
show like that that's possibly like
getting to play Dan and that that's
probably I would try and negotiate it if
I could like get away with just pulling
my hair back and maybe dyeing the color
out of it
but if it was the only way I can play
the part I cut my hair to play that part
which that's saying a lot
have you ever visited the UK yes I
honeymooned in London quite some time
ago what are your favorite musicals um
next to normal is right up there
certainly and certainly as far as recent
ones
I mean I'm partial to rent lame is
hairspray I'm kind of basic having an
accused fund that's a good one I think
I'm the only one who actually enjoys
trolls I want to keep them as pets
there's so much fun to play with
ah dang must meet a super lot too I went
through such a big next to normal phase
a couple years ago it's such a great
soundtrack it is that is that is okay I
need to phantom I enjoy phantom um
phantom is a great spectacle show is
that is that so I'm popping on over the
discord so anybody who puts a question
while I'm doing that I'm not gonna see
it so hold onto it until I'm off the
discord cuz otherwise I will miss it cuz
when I come back I'm gonna be behind
that I'm not gonna go back and scroll
through everything so I don't think
there's gonna be a ton on the discord
this time but let's see I am aware of
trans stuff yeah me yes you are not sure
we'll make it tonight but enjoy the live
stream I have my brother's 24th birthday
to celebrate oh good well that's nice I
hope they have a good time is
international men's day today's
international men's day so trans men
awareness yes because international
men's day would would include trans men
so cheers to that
uh does copa have you concerned about
the future of creators on YouTube um yes
I will actually have a video out on
Thursday sort of talking about Coppa and
the what's going on with all that I
don't really want to delve into it too
much here because it's depressing but
yeah are there any busy video Eddie you
know mm-hmm are there any video essays
you've seen that stand out or
particularly great
I mean individual essays it's harder for
me to say I mean there are some
wonderful video essayists out there like
I I really love Lindsay Ellis way if
you're talking anything film related I
think she does the best work like full
stop
he hasn't done a video essay in a long
time but like his proper video essays
things like really that good movie Bob
Bob Shipman can't be quite good I I have
been enjoying some of the more
philosophical video essays on things
like philosophy tuber innuendo studios
or h-bomb or guy although I do like
innuendo studios in each Bromberg I
doing more sort of entertainment video
essays on things like video games and
movies and whatnot those are really good
as well
um renegade cut I've tried to watch I'm
not sure what it is it has quite clicked
with me I might try them again but it it
hasn't really much there gender-fluid is
a part of trans community do you ever
have issues with in the community
me being bi I have experience in her
community problems not serious about
small things well yeah yeah and I've
talked about this before I am off the
discord now I've talked about this
before that certainly back when I was
identifying as a crossdresser as opposed
to gender fluid or any type of trans I
the the harshest pushback I ever got and
it's not from all of these sorts of
people but the harshest pushback I ever
got was from trans women who found my
presence
threatening for reasons that I actually
understand because transwoman work very
hard to not be perceived as a man at
address so if I'm in anywhere near their
space and at the time I was openly a man
and address they feel threatened didn't
undercut by that of course you know the
actual problem isn't me it's the people
who are lumping you know a crossdresser
in with an actual trans woman as if it's
the same thing when it's not but there
would be anger that would be taken out
of me for that again not all trans woman
not even a majority a minority but it
was by far the harshest pushback I ever
got back in the day and when I did my
video over on the beer Wilde channel a
few months back about being trans
without dysphoria I got it and I knew I
was going to I got a bit of pushback on
that again not the majority of responses
but there are some very harsh and
ultimately what it comes down to more
often than not is nobody if you think
you've got stuff figured out nobody
likes to have that challenged on major
fundamental things I mean nobody does
myself included
if you approach a situation accepting
that you don't know everything going on
with it you you can usually operate it
in that space a little bit better but if
you believe very sincerely I know how
this works when something comes along
that says well no you don't because this
people give very threatened by that and
people can't push back very very hard on
that I just came out to one side of my
family how did you handle this
Oh coming out is a continual process
first person I ever came out to was my
daughter's mother later on there were it
was always easier to come out to people
who I knew relatively recently as
opposed to people I'd known along
because they they would have to update
their mental conception of me whereas
people I was meeting for the first time
I tell them early on and they that just
becomes how they understand me I came
out to my mother and she was really the
only family member who I had a proper
coming out with eventually pretty much
the rest of the family found out either
by finding things like the bear wild
channel on their own or when I came out
publicly through social media two years
ago or a year and a half so you know I I
didn't have that many people to actually
come out directly to and at this point I
am out so publicly that like I'm caught
off guard when it turns out people don't
know I'm like really I just not it's not
hidden let's see I got a backup I've
been rambling for a while and I keep
losing the losing the thread do you know
about the great asexual representation
in the outer worlds or the terrible one
in death stranding um I don't I know
both games exists and I heard outer
worlds is great now her death stranding
is a very special kind of mess but no I
hadn't heard about that specifically and
I have a case or if I did I forgot I
think because I don't actually play
those games myself my memory of them
fades very quickly even when I learned
stuff about them because it doesn't get
read for read for my actual experience
of playing it will you ever do a theater
livestream if you haven't already um I
don't know never thought about that I'm
not sure how I'd frame that um like just
discussing theater in general I mean I
could maybe uh maybe keep that in in the
back pocket my favorite musical is into
the woods that is a really interesting
musical and I tend to reference that
movie as one of my I was one of my go-to
examples of failing to adapt to a new
medium properly so one time a Jehovah's
Witness was at our house but my mom said
she was a Muslim the same witness
returned the next day with an ex Muslim
who converted in an attempt to convert
her they can be persistent I could never
feel threatened by you Vera I'll thank
you thank you very much
dragging crossdressers make me
incredibly uncomfortable I don't push
people about it but I just try to avoid
the things that make me uncomfortable
and that's fair Diana
like I will I won't be mone anyone for
you know making their own choices about
what spaces they want to inhabit be they
physical spaces or online spaces that
they're not comfortable being in that's
you take care of yourself if you're not
comfortable there don't be there but you
know I have had at various points some
very harsh bite back this for you or no
dysphoria you are valid oh thank you
very much as a trans girl I apologize
sincerely you do not have to apologize
for anyone other than yourself and if
you personally have not done anything
wrong you don't have to apologize no one
is responsible for the actions of
whatever group they happen to identify
with or be a part of you are responsible
for yourself I don't experience
dysphoria identifying where the gender I
was assigned at birth but I have a
preference for androgyny online hence
using they then where possible okay that
makes sense to me did you hear about
Noah Hawley writing directing the next
Star Trek if so any thoughts he not
really only because he keeps getting
attached to
that doesn't pan out he was working on
dr. doom too so I don't know if it gets
further along I'll have an opinion I'm
always curious as to what he's up to
okay what is the deal with Blair White
nothing that I feel like talking about
how about that reverse the polarity of
the gender flow questioning and
undecided exists for a reason they're
applicable yes yeah absolutely
it is okay to not know what you are and
even if you do know what you are it's
okay for that to change crazy notion
that who you are can actually change
maybe not everything about everyone is
an immutable fact that is always and
forever for some people this stuff is
always one thing for some of us it's not
and changing is valid and what you were
prior to your change was valid what you
are after your change was valid and
having changed from one thing to another
or having hung out in a place of I don't
freaking know currently or previously
does not invalidate you as a person in
any way shape or form I would definitely
watch discussion of star kids plays I
still have to watch twisted it's right
there I'm staring at it uh I've had that
for a while I feel really guilty ah I
want to get your book in part because I
want to write a trans character as a
protagonist first story and I want to do
my research plus it gives you money
there's no downside oh thank you Ben
thank you very much for that that is a
wonderful thought I I really want to I'm
gonna try and keep my stuff in the
to do it next year get an audio version
of the book out so that it's that it's
available and something people have
access to that's where if you're
interested I have a brief video on my
channel about the outer worlds one I
might take a look at that do you
introduce yourself by both of your names
or just one um
by and large I will introduce myself by
whatever name feels most appropriate for
the circumstances that are being
introduced in meaning that you if I'm
meeting someone in a queer space or a
burlesque related space I will probably
introduce myself as Vera if I am meeting
someone more in a you know in a in a
geek space could go either way
Nathaniel's are probably a little bit
more likely if it is neither of those
things clear-cut honestly flip a coin
off inside I'd often times I decide in
the moment it's not an uncommon
occurrence for Liz and I to be out
somewhere together and she'll see
someone who she knows who I have met yet
and she'll turn to me and go who am i
introducing you as right now like and it
doesn't bother her either way she's just
like I just want to know so I'd
recommend the recording of the stage
version of ITT W I feel really bad for
not knowing what itt w is the playhouse
version i think it works about it oh
into the woods works better than the
adaptation with more charm and
consistent performances well here's the
thing about into the woods fundamentally
the movie was never going to work
properly because that original work was
tailored to the stage because it pivots
on the act break it pivots on the
intermission
because act one ends with everything
being bright and shiny and happily ever
after intermission starts and while
you're getting up and stretching your
legs and going to the bathroom and all
that stuff it starts to dawn on you wait
that felt like an ending what's gonna go
on after that what else is there to do
and it prepares you for the gearshift of
the very different direction of the
second act of that show without an
intermission and just flowing from one
to the others that is a gear shift that
sends the entire thing off the rails
because it was designed and written with
the intermission in mind and taking
advantage of something that is unique to
theater that doesn't exist in film so
when you adapt it to film guess what
suddenly it doesn't work
are you happy with how far the channels
come and if you could cast another
female doctor who would you cast I am
happy with the channel growth I mean I'm
not gonna lie it would have been nice to
keep the kind of growth that I was
seeing at the end of last year as a
steady pace that has slowed down growth
wise but I'm still very happy and as far
as I mean pie-in-the-sky be tilda
swinton failing that I'd take Lena
Headey you should get some reusable
hello my name is badges like I should
just have them stacked like alternating
Nathaniel Vere anything weird like take
just take off the top one whenever I
feel like changing until I run out what
would you say the most underrepresented
part of the lgbtq+ community is um I'm
not sure I'm in a position to say
because I know and I learned this when I
have my non-binary conversation with em
a little while back there is a lot of
representation just in areas that I
don't partake in like there is some
types of representation in anime you can
argue whether or not it's good
representation but there's a fair amount
of representation in things like anime
web comics and things like that that I
just don't know enough about if we're
going to talk mainstream I would say
that the non-binary spectrum is probably
still the most underrepresented and I
say spectrum because that would include
gender fluid a gender by gender
non-binary and and and a number of
others now even that said it's getting
better like I'm watching it get better
I'm watching non-binary actors get
non-binary roles and is awesome if you
were to like to boil down to a real
specific sliver that that's harder for
me to to sort of pin down that's why I
sort of one with the spectrum
non-binary as opposed to parsing it out
with all the all the specificity I
really like I'm between names right now
it's so open and vulnerable ah that is
nice I like that Riverdale is exploited
of buying this cup yeah Liz watches
Riverdale and she she has complained
about that billions TV show yeah I
haven't seen billions but I do know
about the non-binary character on that
new Charlie's Angels flopped because the
last two were bad nothing Charlie's
Angels flopped because no one has cared
about that property since its original
airing I mean the first reboot was kind
of a novelty oh they rebooted it but now
we live in the age of reboots something
being rebooted isn't a novelty anymore
so you're arguing that the previous two
films which were the which were the the
rebooted ones with Drew Barrymore and
Cameron Diaz and Lucy Liu wrecked the
brand I would argue there honestly
wasn't much interest in the brand beyond
the novelty of it having been rebooted
in the first place so Asia Kate Dillon
was great in John Luke chapter 3 which I
still haven't seen I need to and finding
out they were non-binary was great my
partner even used their character as a
hair reference oh cool there's
apparently a non-binary character in the
new season of Discovery named Adira I
still haven't seen any of Discovery it
appears to be incredibly divisive among
Trek fans and being a more casual Trek
fan myself I have no idea what that says
for how much I'm I would or wouldn't
enjoy it
all right I think probably gonna wrap it
up soon did you know in Riverdale a cult
leader tries to escape from a mum
wielding a gun in a rocket ship whilst
wearing a Stars and Stripes jumpsuit
with his name on yes that happened no no
IIIi did not know about that so I'm just
wondering what do you count as an
episode in terms of your patron requests
23 minutes 45 minutes a full hour do you
count each the same or a - 23 minute
episodes count as a 45 minute one
generally the way I've approached it is
an episode is whatever an episode of the
thing is so if it's shorter thing you
know the the base level Commission
review gets you two episodes it would be
two episodes now that said depending on
what it is I might be willing to
negotiate on that like it you'd have to
hit me up and we talk specifics about it
but broadly speaking I when I say
episode I mean whatever however long an
episode of that thing is thank you would
love it as a lot of LGBT representation
which is why it's so divisive I have
heard that but I've also heard from a
fair number of Trek fans that I know who
I know don't have any issue with that
end of things and still don't really
like it I do know about that end of the
device in this though did you ever
return to inside number nine I don't I
never did I did the first series I see
why some people liked it it was just too
inconsistent for me and what I didn't
like it I really didn't like it
the Marvel Disney Plus shows better get
blu-ray releases otherwise my collection
is worthless I don't know I don't even
know what gets released on blu-ray these
days like I I still try and get physical
media for the stuff I really care about
but stole that it is hard you've told me
a lot about gender-fluid
oh thank you Julie I don't like Star
Trek discovery because the themes that
aren't feeling like Star Trek and the
focus on action war instead of broader
ideas yeah that's kind of what I've
heard ever read a who comic sort of I
read a free comic book day sort of thing
I rarely enjoy comic book continuations
of films or TV they just rarely do much
for me hey I'm gonna wrap up soon folks
yeah it really is inconsistent so this
is inside number nine we're talking
about which is a shame because there's
great episodes in there but identifying
which are worth washing would feel like
spoiling
yeah I'm now fair enough how I posada do
you like TV shows to be do you prefer
one continuous narrative or a lot of
little stories it depends on the vibe of
the thing I think some things really
lend themselves to serialization
something's really lend themselves to
one-off stories some things can actually
straddle the line and do a little bit of
both by and large when it comes to
Doctor Who
I like the standalone episodic stories
better than the continuing bridging
serialized ones but when it comes to
something like I mean there's a lot of
great serialized television Fargo is
amazing Legion was incredible
and you know that's our breaking bad
these are incredibly serialized shows
and I don't think wasn't one is
inherently better than the other I think
it depends on the story that you're
telling and how well that story lends
itself to that some setups just worked
very well with a whole new thing each
week doctor who works very well for that
legends of tomorrow works very well for
that the librarians worked very well for
that all right I'm gonna try and catch
up on a few questions and then I'm gonna
wrap it up blu-rays or DVDs blu-rays if
I can get it why are they bringing
Palpatine back I know why but why will
he even work without Vader
well they do the same thing with kylo
it'll be read I'm Palpatine is the main
reason that I am very very very very
nervous about the rise of Skywalker six
dr. comics from DWM are really good well
basically anything six doctor that isn't
the show's tends to be pretty good did
you know that there's a new Blithe
Spirit movie coming out Judi Dench is
playing Madame Arcadia nope didn't know
that not even entirely sure I know what
that is what do you think about bat
woman on the CW haven't seen it I have
not had time
a viewer Commission to review a missing
doctor whose story how would you go
about it one of the visual
reconstructions are audio recreation
with linking narrations on audible um
well honestly that would be the
commissioners choice if they have a
preference for which I would do if they
did not have a preference I would
probably go for the anime of recreation
if it exists but with multiple options
like that I I would I would default to
if someone was commissioning me to do
that my husband's sister is trans
her after she came out is like night and
day
she seems so much more comfortable in
her own skin she used to be so
introverted before I love it oh that's
wonderful the best dinosaur the best
dinosaur hmm and Clea Soros and some
Doctor Who finales they pull stuff from
previous episodes in the series the FOB
watch satellite five would you prefer
the series just did this and ditched
mystery boxes I don't know because all
that is like it's still tied into
mystery box storylines they've never
like just done that by itself without it
also being a mystery box for missing
Doctor Who episodes you could also read
the original target novelizations but
time is precious yeah that's the least I
get first of all they'd have to
Commission me at the Commission a book
thing which is a separate more expensive
to your than commissioning me to watch
episodes of the show and there's a
reason for that so takes a lot longer a
respectable choice for second best
dinosaur dinosaurs with things on their
tails are best very nice velociraptor
liz has had times that she has told me
that sometimes she wakes up very
irritated at the fact that she's not a
velociraptor clever girl
all right I I think I am gonna wrap it
up there so I hope everybody had a good
evening and that you have a good rest of
the week and yeah like this will never
be the default for these streams like
this this takes a while for me to put my
face on but it is
nice to do every now and then and I
really like that I'd have a space and a
community and a fanbase where I can feel
safe and supporting to do this when I
feel the desire to so thank you for that
thank you for listening thank you for
everything
I wish you all the best
just remember that you are beautiful you
are valid you are loved you are the
council I just from the meetings have a
good night